I'm so sorry we're not taking you sorry
bakery got they here honey come here
baby boy what's up guys today is a very
exciting day if you can't tell I'm
wearing purple
Ed's wearing purple Maddy's wearing
purple Danika purple
I switched thousand steps today is the
day that Matt nadeshot heads back to
twitch we are heading over to his
livestream that he's doing at Red Bull I
need my purse you're coming with us this
somebody got Maddie from flowers to
Maddie's yeah that's you honey
rolling to Red Bull welcome to red both
my daughter's trendy we're gonna go we
had to let him down a little because
whenever used the groomers then he comes
back he's like a fluffy little cotton
ball and a little too fluffy oh yeah oh
my god oh my god
we brought the dog well he's named after
you
you named me hold on so there's a really
good chance bring the dog we see a
really good chance he might poop on
stream he's gonna know we're not home
ago they said it's okay
and you can see if you poops in here
pants and shirt it's not cool to boot up
here is this an awesome congratulation
yes the mic hold on I gotta eat
I need you guys to hey guys what's wrong
let me hit up some peeps we're here at
the rebel Studios freaking rebel this is
how we two Maddie's having a good time
man you've been a good boyfriend Matt
scream I don't even know who to hit up
for where that's an eye thing like
skiers go to something I can throw bombs
there is presents I feel like I did that
- Matt good wax I just got to figure out
I got fine people that's good idea wax
some more NASA crack open fork go I'll
go and Iran so we're gonna head moving
out of the water
okay keep talking man riding 2926 girl
train gon let me hit up scum let me hit
up scum my mother got dinner grab that
back we're now getting pizza actually I
got salmon so I didn't even get pizza ed
got pizza I got to pee flow one pizza in
one minute
net shut up dogs just had their kangaroo
I'm really sad the Baker's gonna be
leaving us
he's been my baby for OB yeah yeah yeah
Richard you can go hop up on my lap
everybody could look in my back the
sweet Maddie's like wait but what about
me I'm so proud of Matt he's back on
Twitch but Yolo we got asked him why
we're wearing purple yeah it's because
we're celebrating twitch I didn't we
didn't go into why we're wearing it
because I feel like would have not made
sense to anybody wertheimer's like quit
jeez use the hashtag like I'm still
haven't at work right now because I'm
missing the street okay dogs honey
diggers over here good boy you did - yes
you did very well
you guys let's sit down a little bit so
we had a fun time at Matt's stream a Red
Bull and now today Maddie who is 5%
Matt's dog at least that's what I said
personal means how many trends is Matt
taking Maddie for a walk 5% of his walk
I'm not so sure if that is but either
way the stream was often been out today
Maddie is on his first commercial shoot
and I'm so excited for you guys to see
it look at you you're handsome he's so
tired because he's been running around
this place like a mad puppy so he's
going to be playing a DJ I am so pumped
he's my dog client yeah you guys don't
know avatars my manager and work with
him forever and you know what I'm just
getting a new corner I did a mini moon
to moon rocket messing another thing do
you guys remember when I did that pig
video the music video a long time ago
the trainer that came with that pig she
is here today on the shoot so bring it
all around full circle can you believe
it that's a good song go watch that
later anyway we're here Maddie's got a
suit on he's handsome as ever
see I'm excited if you guys see this I'm
gonna drink a ginger ale and sit here on
white it's a name in the game when
you're on film sets
all right sit hurry up and wait yeah
we're in the scene
it's true and it's hot huh did you ask
me about vlogging yeah I can't login the
cameras broken this vlog is a part of
when we went to Matt Street
yes I didn't film it up so it's like
well I'd like to make it longer and then
I filmed a little bit yesterday Mattie
shoot I wanted to make it longer and
here we are we're shopping because it's
our sister's wedding shower in a week so
we're looking for dresses and just some
things that aren't sweatpants I've seen
that 50 times here and I've hated it
every time don't do a lot did you watch
my mobile shopping vegan food yesterday
no I was shopping for six hours I got a
t-shirt
I've never seen you go wear that to the
baby shower it could be your dress it's
a little big 197 dollars
person fresh oh this is nice everything
that looks that's a hundred and three
dollars this is looks like this looks
like a dishrag looks like when I
accidentally clean my bathroom with
bleach and a head of broccoli I like
it's really cute
ooh I like the blue as well able to is
it you can really clear it's a little
chilly I think choppiness sucks I wish I
could just learn nothing
down here let me know what you see by
foil let me know if you think I should
come back up there we just got home I
think I'm gonna finally end this vlog of
three days of whatever is combined into
this I got a couple cute things today I
did get a dress and a nice flannel shirt
I you should have a flannel shirt
problem do you remember that oh yeah
did your ice cream it's so always too
frozen for him but no oh my god it
smells good Punk it's basically just
like that smells delicious really yogurt
with pumpkin can we eat it there's other
stuff in there there's a 4-pack I was
cool wouldn't Maddie found out he was
ten years older he said it's a
continuation of the blog that I haven't
ended this is the vlog that'll never end
if it goes on and on my friend Maddie
actually looks like Lambchop Maddie are
you Lambchop how many questions gonna
ask you before you bite me so we're off
to Beverly Hills to get our eyebrows
done really riveting content here still
preparing for Brienne's big wedding
shower I don't have a dress I don't have
any to wear my iPhone is dead I don't
have a backup battery do you have a movi
my Apple watch bands came in so going to
be doing a video of those a table of
doom we've got Apple watches we pop
those life
we've got tampons and more tampons and
trash bag this office is the disaster
you ready Jen okay when we find some
shoes these God sing in it not knowing
what it was and he'll continue staying
in it forever what's wrong I was little
the words whoever did because this is
the song that does it and guess it goes
on and on my friend some people started
singing it not knowing what it was and
now continue singing it forever just
because this is a song that doesn and
yes it'll go on and on Maddie my friend
and I'll continue singing it forever
just you know what I was thinking this
is so cute
this is Maddie's I think I won't get one
for myself I think I'm gonna wear it
missed you a double loop hey come see
this new bracelet I just got that's how
a bracelet
Kevin candy did you tell him the cookies
mmm they came to this cute little bucket
and like a cookie bouquet I think there
was a dozen there's four loved just
another car vlog just another car vlog
run away Beverly Hills Beverly Hills
that's where I wanna be
it's right last time I was there it took
me 45 minutes to find a parking spot
Syria not available
what the heck can you play Beverly Hills
that's where I want to be Weezer sorry I
couldn't find we should never be helping
her be a second oh my phone's broken
like it says Siri not available I'm not
connected to the Internet how is is to
get to worry we need to get to without
the internet I don't know how to get to
Beverly Hills
it's basically straight I just see it
from here couple the iPhone se
I don't even see it it's you're grounded
sugar and go back
the whole zayn album video i have it
before that face high - it really looks
good
truth capital r capital t turn left
one mile well I'm gonna prep we're going
to earth cafe it's uh probably one of my
top favorite restaurants in LA it's a
little high for now as you describe it
well it's called earth cafe so it's a
little earthy earthy they've got salads
with your eggs hi oh I'm just calling to
see if you guys are still in business I
heard that you weren't oh okay great
perfect thank you I swear true but look
we would issue we looked at the line it
was cafe which is why we just went in a
circle 50 times and then don't make any
moves there's a restaurant called Jack
and Jill but I swear to you and start
oven close can you believe we're going
to Jack and Jill can you believe I
called them and it's a height and they
answered and I was starstruck dude she's
everything probably will hear it oh she
will traffic arrived at 1:11 p.m. I
didn't know you were filming I haven't
stopped filming well we have parking
will piss off
yeah probably no parking no I've already
wanted to like throw myself in front of
my own car I'm a good driver because I
love someone I stand in right now I'm
too emotional everyone I too emotional
everyone long pills everyone is freaking
out of a freaking mind it's like you're
crossing in the middle of an
intersection and you shouldn't be what
are you doing
I probably intended yes I don't think
anyone here this isn't your demographic
oh my kids playing on his Louisiana
quarter mile turn right onto West Third
Street you know I gotta turn left the
North Oakland and West I will shower
toward South hillcrist we've been trying
to get here for a long time and now
we're here and I don't want I want to go
home we did Jenna we have to go to the
store I don't even know how to pronounce
it they make some of my favorite band
t-shirt the Metallica shirt that I
cannot find did you paint it you wore it
last you wore my Metallica shirt
laughing you destroyed it different
brought it back where it was Ellie
months ago and I haven't had since we
made the Jack and Jill I'm so glad I
haven't been here in so long I've
actually never currently been to this
location they have the same food they've
got the mini muffins and my phone
actually it wasn't working
I pay my bill so I paid it and hopefully
my photos are working again I finished
in October 2014 I check in but my folks
still isn't working out I'm an idiot you
don't even know what you might have said
I want to hit stop recording and I
caught it like this my heart flip these
over make you look oh there's a
beautiful boy let me see your name it's
gone you're so fast but I wish I had a
time stamp it was two seconds okay I'll
have the bacon thank you no let me show
you something
me
we're still trying to find from
awareness doing okay I like this little
short we're not getting our brows done
this is before brows Bibi my goodness
you're a Content thief Jenna said the
same exact thing in a video but here we
are it's probably not going to look any
different
let's go content after
do they look the same maybe doesn't
matter shouldn't want to buy yourself a
present it's so perfect look at this
it's a shark
case I know it's beautiful but no one
will help us here are you a lego
collaboration those are actual Lego
bricks
that was way too fancy
the shark iPhone case is only for the
six not six plus there she go let's
cross
shall we like a Beverly Hills that's
where Jenna wants to move please not let
me please okay officially ending this
vlog now hey bye Maddie
say bye Jenna I have a good Friday Happy
Easter I'll see you guys probably
tomorrow hopefully tomorrow I actually
film the Apple watch unboxings so that
really want to wear them see you later
this is good everything's good
everything's great everything's awesome
I'm having a good time
Oh work out for the day